hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor
today we're talking about photosynthesis
and cell respiration
basically we're going to look at how
those two are connected
and what they have in common now they're
actually a lot more connected
than most people think they're part of a
larger
cycle that starts with energy that comes
from the sun
that sun provides light energy that is
absorbed by
chloroplasts
this is where photosynthesis happens
photosynthesis
yields two types of products first
organic molecules
the most common you'll hear about is
glucose so a type of sugar
the other major product yielded by
photosynthesis
is oxygen or o2
organic molecules like glucose and
oxygen
are then used by mitochondria and
cellular respiration
this is where the mitochondria has
enzymes present
that through several complicated steps
break down organic molecules use oxygen
as a final electron acceptor to generate
something very very important atp
atp is basically the energy
currency of the cell it's like a dollar
bill
everywhere in the cell takes it and this
is where energy is stored
that the cell can later use for a
variety of
cellular processes now where does the
cycle
part come in in mitochondria with cell
respiration
once they have used the organic
molecules and the oxygen
there are two different products that
are formed these are
carbon dioxide and water
carbon dioxide and water are the two
reactants that chloroplasts need to
carry out photosynthesis
so that is how this is one big cycle
now let's look at what these processes
photosynthesis and cell respiration what
do they have in common
well they both use electron transport
chains
electron transport chains are these
series of enzymes that are part of
biological
membranes that pass electrons
from place to place within that chain
and
in so doing they harvest energy from
those electrons
and create something called a proton
gradient the proton gradient is then
used
in both photosynthesis and cell
respiration
by atp synthase
and this is another common misconception
people think that atp
is only involved in cell respiration and
it's true that cell respiration is where
the cell
gets the atp that it needs for all of
its different
functions but photosynthesis has atp
synthase as well
in photosynthesis atp synthase is used
to generate atp in an early step of
photosynthesis
that is then used up in a later step of
photosynthesis
where the organic molecules are being
made so
atp is a part of both of these things
also both both photosynthesis
and cell respiration occur in plants
algae and photosynthetic bacteria
people are tempted to say that
autotrophs like plants use
photosynthesis
and heterotrophs like animals use cell
respiration
that's true but actually plants use
both and algae and photosynthetic
bacteria
they use both they use the
photosynthesis to
generate the organic molecules and the
oxygen and they use the mitochondria
that they have
for cell respiration to get the atp that
they need
for all of their various functions
now i also want to mention as a side
note that photosynthetic bacteria
you might be saying well how can they
have photosynthesis
they don't have chloroplasts that's true
bacteria are prokaryotic cells and they
lack organelles
so they don't have chloroplasts they
don't have mitochondria
instead the enzymes that are used in
photosynthesis
and cell respiration they have as a part
of their plasma
membrane instead of being specifically
in the cell in these compartmentalized
places
now another thing that the two processes
have in common is that they use
biological membranes for increased
surface area
what does this mean well cells
are very small places and they have a
lot going on
inside of them you see that chloroplasts
have this double membrane system
and then on the inside they've got more
membranes the membranes here are in
black and the mitochondria
also is a double membrane you've got the
outer membrane and then you've got this
inner membrane that has
lots and lots of folds these folds are
called
cristae
in chloroplasts all of these individual
little ovals
are called thylakoids
and the thylakoids when stacked together
in a column like this
form what's called a granum
but regardless of the terminology in
both cases you have a lot
of biological membrane that is folded up
into a very little space and it's these
biological membranes
the thylakoid membranes and the cresting
membranes that hold those electron
transport chains
where a big portion of photosynthesis
and cell respiration
is happening so by having all of these
folds or all of these stacks of
thylakoids
this provides a lot of increased surface
area
so that photosynthesis and cell
respiration can happen
at a very high rate there's a lot of it
going on at once
because it has all of this surface area
to work with
even though it's in these small
compartments and finally another place
that photosynthesis and cell respiration
are
linked is in the endosymbiotic theory
this theory deals with the evolution of
eukaryotes
so eukaryotes as different from
prokaryotes
eukaryotes are these cells that have a
lot of
membrane bound organelles so organelles
like chloroplasts like mitochondria
but also other organelles as well
lysosomes
endoplasmic reticulum the golgi
apparatus
the nucleus all of these are specific
to eukaryotes the endosymbiotic theory
says that mitochondria
and chloroplasts are special though that
they were formed
when an early ancestor of eukaryotic
cells
engulfed a photosynthetic prokaryote
that then became a chloroplast and a
non-photosynthetic prokaryote that then
became a mitochondrion
and that these two organelles come
from this ancient
symbiosis that was formed when
prokaryotes were
engulfed by an early eukaryote so that
is
one other thing that photosynthesis and
cell respiration have
in common that is it for today i hope
you enjoyed and thanks for watching